monsieur le ministre elle s'appelait
Vanessa elle avait 14 ans
ce samedi 18 novembre elle rentre du
collège pour gagner le domicile de ses
parents à Tournai vit le Cher au
sénateur Moga dans notre département du
Lot-et-Garonne au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment
vanessa est enlevé violet étranglé par
un individu connu des services de
justice pour des faits antérieurs commis
lorsqu'il avait 15 ans
il avait alors été condamné à 15 jours
d'emprisonnement a sorti d'un sursis
avec une mise à l'épreuve de deux ans il
n'était pas astreint ni à aucun contrôle
judiciaire à aucun contrôle par une
association de d'insertion et de
probation il n'était pas non plus
inscrit au fichier d'auteurs
d'infractions à caractère sexuel et
pourtant
c'est grâce au visionnage de la vidéo
surveillance de la ville qu'il a pu être
interpellé rapidement monsieur le
ministre le Lot-et-Garonne est en deuil
un deuil d'autant plus cruel que c'est
la troisième petite fille qui est
enlevée sur le chemin de l'école
elle s'appelait Vanessa elle avait 14
ans monsieur le ministre c'est davantage
la vice-présidente de l'association La
Mouette association de prévention de
l'enfance qui vous interpelle et plus
que d'une question c'est un appel au
secours monsieur le ministre votre
gouvernement est-il prêt à donner plus
de moyens à la justice pour assurer un
contrôle réel et efficace à l'endroit de
ces individus votre gouvernement est-il
prêt à aider tous nos villages toutes
nos villes afin que toutes nos écoles et
tous nos collèges soient équipés de
caméra et puis monsieur le ministre vous
parlez souvent du principe de précaution
monsieur le ministre êtes-vous prêt à
ouvrir enfin les portes de l'éducation
nationale afin que les associations de
prévention de l'enfance puisse faire
leur première mission de prévention afin
de sauver notre bien le plus précieux la
vie de nos enfants merci